right now i want to highlight a friend
of the show a member of the drew's crew
who helped us create beautiful spaces
for some very wonderful people
throughout season one call him alumni
here's the best of celebrity interior
designer
mikael welsh
please welcome someone i'm such a fan of
design expert and very good friend of
the show masterful artiste mikel welch
well hello
what i've created for you two ladies are
two separate twin beds now you needed a
headboard didn't want to break the bank
so there's an easy solution for this
i've done a painted headboard and then
you just layer everything up with a
bunch of pillows and you can complete
this project for less than thirty
dollars it's
so brilliant macau the girls really
needed some additional storage right and
so i've given them a new dresser and
then i just did a simple mirror just to
kind of balance things off and you
cannot miss this girl right here i mean
the pompous grass faux chandelier is the
star of the show cristal are those happy
tears
macau your client is happy i gave you
these cute little planters right here
and it just allows you an opportunity to
bring all of those you know fresh
greenery moments and to actually display
them you know oftentimes we just push
greenery into a corner but it's like no
like get it up off the floor let us see
it it's a very zen like moment another
thing i want to point out that i was
really inspired by mikael in your
choices was that you echoed
the window treatment
to the closet what we were able to do
was to put drapes on the outside of the
closet and what that does it does a
couple of things so first it kind of
separates the space so it doesn't feel
as cluttered but then it's giving you
that optical illusion so you kind of
feel like you're in a much bigger space
it's super smart well natalie and
christelle what do you think of the room
we love the room it's amazing i like the
closet and the beds looked so this is
like amazing yeah you're finally in our
perfect group
thank you thank you so much
i'm super excited to show you your new
room i wish i could give you a hug i
know i can't i'm a hugger but i know i
can't michael i'm really excited to
learn from you and how you approached
this room
and gloria's closet okay so gloria i
think the biggest solution for you was
to add an oversized wardrobe which we've
done here honey we have storage and
storage and more storage so if you see
here we have hanging bars so you can get
all of your longer hanging amazing order
and then check this out we've got all of
these roll out bins so you know how you
have like your t-shirts sometimes you
roll them up like you can put jeans
t-shirts everything and you look like a
bling type of girl so i know bing bling
bling yeah you're into jewelry so we've
even got you jewelry
amazing so now everything
this is a lot of bling i gotta control
it all here so
check this out
that's beautiful i know right now you
can help
every single shoe and then last but not
least uh over here we gave you some
double hangs so you can amazing lots of
clothes you have lots and lots and lots
of storage over here and then did you
personalize the handles
i did i did
it looks good so we were putting the
design together and i had just like a
pretty ottoman and drew was like no like
she needs to like have some function so
drew said she wanted a storage ottoman
love it so now
you can have extra storage if your
husband gets on your nerves you can put
him in there too so listen you're
covered i'm going to lock my door
padlock on the front once it looks
beautiful because nobody's coming in
it's beautiful michael you're beautiful
so amazing absolutely it's like a dream
come true thank you so much thank you
i'm glad you liked it
i cannot wait till our next project
[Laughter]
oh my god you're in my mouth how does it
look oh my god my cow is here right now
i painted it you did that yourself no
girl i was about to be really impressed
i know
we had a little situation with the toys
i had to donate them um i'm joking oh my
god oh my god i love what mikael did i
don't think this is a designed by drew
this is straight up a designed by
mikhail
i cannot wait to see what mikael does in
season two and i'll be right there by
his side as design is my happy place
[Music]